[Music]
[Music]
this is the first in a two-part series
of webinar some go presents on
extracting data from the web and what
we're gonna look at today is how to get
data that's been already packaged for
you in a web api a lot of times when
people want to share their through the
web they go through the trouble to make
an API which makes it easier for you to
get that data on November 30th we'll
follow up this with a web scraping
webinar which will show you how to just
go out and scrape the data that you want
right off the web pages when it's not
been prepackaged into an API the topic
we're going to cover today touches on
something very deep and that is actually
the topic of web api is and web
development and i'm not going to go so
deep into that that's not my expertise
and what i will be teaching you is a
package called HTT r which is an r
package that allows you to use HTTP web
api so with our the HTT r package is
actually very simple to use so if you
are a web developer and you are familiar
with HTTP I think just that maybe you
just look at the vignette the QuickStart
thing yet for a CTR it's about 1,500
words by taking less than 10 minutes to
read which is shorter than this webinar
I put the link up here right now in case
you're watching this in the future right
now and you think this might be a better
way for you to wrap up because what I'm
going to do is focus on what HTTP is
what Web API assets are now go assume
that the people need this webinar are
people who have a background like me
where your data scientist or
statistician you've identified the web
as a great place to collect data but you
don't have that background in api's or
web development so you don't necessarily
have the context to use the hitter
package which like I said is a fairly
easy package as you'll see wouldn't get
to that so before we start explaining a
little at the API SAR and whatnot I do
want to acknowledge that these two
webinars both come from a tutorial that
I taught with Scott Chamberlin and
Karthik Graham at the last News
our conference now the webinars are more
concise and self-contained there's no
exercises for you to do so the contents
of these webinars we will put on the our
studio webinar github like we always do
but if you wanted access to the original
content it is available through the our
open site github repository which is the
link right here so that's the original
tutorial I use hard which is much longer
and has exercises or not alright so
let's start with api's what is an API in
general you think of an api as a set of
instructions for how a program shouldn't
interact with a piece of software so if
you create a piece of software does
something useful and you think someone
was writing a program somewhere else
might want to use your software you
would set up an API which which tells
that developer how their program should
send requests or interact with your
piece of software and an API can be you
know an interface to a database to a
computer's operating system to a
software package it does something or
commonly to web applications and we're
going to focus on this last case today
we're going to focus on how you could
use an API to a web data source to
collect data into our if you wanted to
visualize you know how API is work you
could imagine we you could think of
something that you do every day that
vols an API in the background and that's
browsing the Internet when you open a
web page on your computer the pictures
that you've seen the web page the text
the links all that exists somewhere on a
server on the other side of the internet
and your web browser on your computer
locates that server that's storing all
this information it sends a request to
the server using the server's web api
saying please give me the pictures so i
could display them on my users screen
and he or she could see what's like my
web page and then the server sends a
response back that hopefully contains
the pictures in the text everything the
web browser needs to build out web page
locally for you to look at or the server
might send back some sort of error
message saying i can't do that for
whatever reason the instructions the
requests that your web browser sends to
the server are formatted according to
the api that that server uses
or that that program is it so when you
write a piece of software like I guess
Tim berners-lee the Internet you can
decide how you want this all to work and
the name one wants to work with that
software should follow your rules
otherwise your software's not gonna
respond the way that they want so when
your web browser connects to the web
server there's a specific way of doing
that that your web browser uses and that
is with an API protocol called HTTP and
that's what we're going to look at here
today on HTTP is standard for all sorts
of web interfaces I mentioned for mine
my background is not in web development
I imagine there are some exotic places
where you might find something other in
HTTP experimental locations but really I
don't know of any so I think HTTP is
pretty standard what we're going to try
to do today is use the HTR package to
equip our to behave like a web browser
in that it can fetch resources from a
web server straight into our those
resources could mean things you see on
web page like images and text or they
could be actual data that's been saved
on the internet for you to download so
let's look at HTTP the protocol that
we'll use in our web api's it stands for
hypertext Transfer Protocol the internet
is basically built on hypertext which is
text that's linked to other pieces of
text and so on and HTTP HTTP itself
revolves around the idea of URLs which
is another acronym for Uniform Resource
locator
and the URL is where you know as a web
addresses we can type into your web
browsers and you can think of the URL
more generally as a file path to a
resource on the Internet and you know
just like a file path on your computer
there are different parts of this URL
that directs your computer to the actual
resources a server to the actual
resource and this is how you identify
the resources that you want to request
or then you want to alter or delete or
whatever you want to do with through the
API in Skov X's there are different
parts of this URL that I've put here and
many of them are optional you know you
very often will have query parameters
or a 90-year without but but all these
things can work together to form a URL
or you might be able to eat a resources
of this the place wws calm okay the way
HTTP organizes you make requests the
client makes requests are sent to the
server the server responds with
responses and both the request message
and the response message are basically
plain text files and they share the same
structure so plain text is really easy
to pass over or over any network and so
HTTP is taking advantage of that if you
wanted to look at an HTTP message that
it sent whether it's a response or your
request it's going to have the same
three-part structure there's going to be
an initial line that contains very
important information what's in that
line will depend on whether or not this
is a request or a response
we'll look at those separately in a
moment there's going to be or there can
be a set of optional headers which are
just key value pairs separated by a
colon
those can contain useful information and
then also optionally there may be a
message body at the end of the message
separate from the beginning by the Glenn
Klein and that message bodies where
contents would be if the message
contains an image or a data set or not
it would be stored here in the message
body if it helps and it helps me I like
to think these three parts is separate
from each other and this is how we
divide up with this template message so
let's look at a sample request you can't
get a response from the server until you
send a request so you need to learn how
to send a request before you learn how
to interpret a response and this would
be a real HTTP request going out to a
webinars page of our studio comm which
is somewhere you've probably visited if
you manage to wind up here and it's just
asking for the information that a web
browser would need to display this web
page on your computer if we look at it
we can see it has that three part
structure although since this request
isn't really sending information for the
server to use is just saying please
server give me something back there's no
body there's no content to it it's just
initial line in some headers with some
metadata and this initial line is broken
into three parts and this is how the
initial line if any and the HTTP request
will be organized the first cycle can
three parts each separated by a space
and the last part for a request is the
most trivial it's the version of HTTP
that the request is using we're not
gonna have to pay attention that next
part is the URL path to the resource
that the message is pertaining to and
you'll notice that this isn't a complete
URL path but your computer will have
already established a connection through
report to the host which is wwr c om so
the host knows what it is
it just needs to know where and all of
its files as a resource and you want to
know about and that's the remaining part
of the URL so here resources slash
webinars takes you to the webinars page
varsity or comm and then the first part
of the first line is probably the most
important part of your request and as an
HTTP verb that tells the server what you
want to do there are a collection a
small collection of verbs that you can
use with HTTP e but the most important
ones are probably the forward I'm gonna
list here using a get verb in that
sample and get is the verb you use when
you want to retrieve a resource that's
specified by a URL you send a get
request to the server and the server
notes that it should send you back what
you're asking for or tell you that you
can't have it it doesn't exist you know
you can also send a post request which
create to the resource out of URL so
when you send a post request to a server
you normally attach some data to it the
server gets this and then it uses that
data to build a new resource at that URL
which will then exist and other people
can get it you can use a poet request
which is similar to post but it works
with resources that already exist use a
put to update that resource with data
that you store in the content of your
message and then you could also send a
delete request which would delete a
resource I exists on that server at that
URL so like I said there's other verbs
but these are the big four the most
important ones and this is really the
place where you as an art
helper need to start paying attention so
the information up till here was all
conceptual is all about you know how the
web is created but these words are
things that you will use from inside a
bar so let's start tuning that the
package that will use an R to send HTTP
requests and we see responses is called
hitter
it's like HTTP but it ends with an R to
use it you can install it from cran like
any package and then load it with
library and to create a request with
hitter you would use a function that
matches one of the verb names
notice these names are all capitalized
so if you want to send a get request you
would use the get function which comes
in hitter and it's capital G et what you
pass to get is the complete URL of the
resource you want to get there's also a
function for example called post in the
new pass a complete URL where you want
to post the new data to and so on we saw
in our HTTP file that the actual HTTP
request sort of divides up this URL but
he knew as an R you don't have to worry
about that again is an R function and
it's going to do some pre-processing in
the background for you all get needs is
the complete URL and they'll take care
of the rest there and then notice I'm
saving something from this function once
get sends the request in this case over
the internet so you'll want to be
connected to the Internet but the server
it accesses is going to send back a
response and get will return that
response as the output of the function
so if I only use that response later I'm
going to save it in here I'm going to
save it so the object are I'm accessing
here website called HTTP org and that's
on purpose this is a website that was
set up as a learning age for HTTP and
basically when you access something
there it just sends back the thing that
you sent to it so if I'm sending a get
message to HTTP pin downwards I should
get HTT bin is go take that message
quickly recompile it into a response and
send it back to me so I could kind of
see what's going on behind the scenes I
can see what I said if you want to add
headers into the HTTP message request
that you're sending over you could do
that by adding the add headers function
as an argument and I name
argument inside of your verb function so
here I'm adding it inside the mid
function pass to add headers a set of
named arguments then you want to become
your headers so I'm just making up a
stupid header that no sir would know
what to do with but I'm saying add this
header name equals Garrett that's my
name and what get and add headers will
do in the background so when it
assembles your message a message will
look like this here's the first line we
see our get that's the verb the part of
the URL that that is needed to go from
the host to the resource which is just
slashed it and then the protocol we're
using which is HTTP you 1.1 and then
there's a header it's the header I added
name colon care the name of the argument
that you select will be the key value of
that key value pair and then what you
set that name to be the value of the key
value pair well then the third part of
any HTTP message is a body and if you
want to add a body to your message you
could do that with the body argument so
normally when you send a get message you
don't need to add a body you're asking
the server sent you data so you sending
data to the server it's kind of
unnecessary and want to use if it
arrived so I'm going to use the post
verb here so the post function creates a
post request then post is the verb that
you use to create a new resource on the
server that new resource that you want
cream you need to pass to the server in
the body of your ear function of your
request
so here I've saved a list with three
elements named a B and C to body I saved
my URL separately I'm passing it into
post
there's my URL then I'm setting the body
argument equal to this list that I
created I'm saying I want this resource
exist on the server I want people to be
able to access it through that URL I
just made and then you could choose how
to encode that data that you're sending
along so if you're working in are the
data that you put together is probably
gonna be a list which is an R object
that you know a Web API won't know what
to do with so the hitter is going to
transform that data into something
that's more commonly used by web api's
and you can choose with the encode
argument how you want to do that to
learn more
codes look at that whole page for posts
but basically you can come as a forum as
multi type data as is raw data which
would just be binary data or as JSON and
here let's make a well let's review
these arguments and then now I want to
make a small tangent to explain what
JSON is so here's our body argument
that's the data we're going to send
across here's how I want to encode it
this last time I'm going to code as JSON
but you can seen the other lines how to
do it differently and then this is what
I would get this is the message that
would be sent to the server now the verb
is post the remaining path for the URL
is slash post we see their protocol
their post itself has created a fairly
informative header that we didn't have
to worry about and then the body the
very last line of this request contains
our very simple let's say equals 1
because 2 C equals 3 but it's been
encoded as JSON which is something that
almost anything on the web will know
what to do with so let's look at what
JSON is just know so you'll be familiar
with it it's another acronym it stands
for JavaScript object notation and it is
also a type of key value pairs organized
hierarchically into a group it's
becoming the standard data format for
web api is there are other for myself
too like XML and so on but you will
probably see JSON and as you start
working with web data you go a little
further you'll encounter it so I wanted
you just be aware of what's there in
terms of JSON and also tool for working
with JSON there is an r package called
json light which is a very simple
package I mean there's only a handful of
functions but it's for working with JSON
data and R and the two primary functions
are to JSON and from JSON to JSON takes
in our object it could be a list or a
data frame in terms of the chase on from
JSON takes JSON saved as a character
string it turns it into an art list now
I say this is a tangent because the
header package is actually pretty good
at isolating you from having to convert
JSON it's doing that in the background
and it's doing it with the JSON light
package but if you ever want to do it
manually JSON light would be a good
place to start ok let's go back to
hitter
there's one more
that you would use with the request
function that's very helpful and that's
this verbose function if you pass
verbose as a function with the
parentheses behind it so called function
into the get function that's an argument
then get function will do what's going
to anyways but it will print out the
actual HTTP that it's sending as a
request it also print out the response
it gets I didn't pay census ID here but
so here you don't have to take my word
for it that these things are making with
the messages I'm showing you on the
screen this is the actual output and you
can see that get is actually adding more
headers than I've been including my
samples and this is sort of what you
could consider going to play for HTTP
it's doing it for you
right so now you know how to create a
response to send out to a server through
URL or a request I should say let's look
at what you will get back when you send
your request the server will process it
and I'll send back a response which is
also a text file it also has three parts
that same three parts and the first line
of it is also probably the most
important line so here's a sample
response here I am dividing it up into
the first line the headers in the body
if you look at the first line the parts
are kind of reversed the first part here
is the HTTP version which again we don't
really pay attention to today the second
part is a status code which tells you
whether you request it succeeded or not
there are a variety different status
codes but here 200 means that this the
request didn't succeed this isn't status
code you always hope to see it means
success and then the last part is sort
of an English explanation of that status
code so every status code is a number
three digit number and the English
explanation helps to understand what
that means you've probably seen status
codes before Justin daily surfing the
web but oftentimes the SAS code will be
put into the web page you're seeing so
you can what goes on so for example if
you go to a place in our scene comet
doesn't exist you will get a 404 status
code or your web browser will receive
that back from the server and 404 means
could not be found and so here the
design if our website put that for for
up there and says this page cannot be
found
so if you
seen this before or other errors like
400 500 just your web browser using the
status code it got back from the server
to try to explain why what you expect it
to happen didn't happen there are a
whole bunch of status codes up there's
so many things that could go wrong or so
many things that sold might want to talk
go save through their API and if you
want to look up any particular status
status code there's a very cute way to
do so at HTTP cap it's a little
confusing that HTTP is the startup
address it's not the beginning of URL so
you'll have to write HTTP place but it
lists all the tasks of it's an acute
admirable way so let's look at the
initial request we need let's get I
saved as our if you want to see what we
got back link it saves its response in
the are you just type are and this is
what I will show you I've truncated a
little bit at the end it shows us that
this is a response to response from this
URL we got at this date and this time
the status was 200 the content types and
back was which base on the size is the
size and we've actually seen the body
down here this is some JSON that was
sent back so we were asking for
something and what we got back was this
JSON
this isn't a direct HTTP message
it's a HTTP message that has been parsed
into an R object because we're now
working in iron and then the background
headers doing some work for us in fact
you could think of this object that's
been saved are as like a model object in
our when you create a model you get all
sorts of information inside an object
our doesn't necessarily know what part
of that you want to see a tank at a time
so it just sort of saves it there and it
gives a slim display when you look at
the object but if you want the rest of
information you'd use a helper function
and header it comes with helper
functions that allow you to access
information that's in this response
object one of the first
functions are one the first piece of
information that you'll want to get is
the status code this is what lets you
know or let your program know whether it
worked you can access the number of the
SAS code very simply with dollar signs
status underscore code
so here the arts worked we got our 200
that means it worked or you get a more
verbose easy or human understandable
status message using the helper function
HTTP underscore status it prints out
this list that has you know different
components but here we see the final one
this was successful
we got the 200 SAS code and the English
equivalent of 200 is okay now when
you're working with AP Isis task code
really does matter if you're not looking
with your own eyes at the message to see
if it worked or not you will want to
program defensively and have your
program check to see whether the status
worked or not so it can then you know
raise an error warning and HCR has two
functions that can help you do that
warn for status will check the object to
see if your the status code was not 200
and if so we'll raise a warning to say
you this was the message and then stop
for SAS does almost increment but
actually stops with an error the other
thing that if you're in the defensive
mindset you should keep in mind is
there's no guarantee that these status
codes are actually the correct code that
comes back you're kind of working here
with someone who develops you know their
server program on their siding you kind
of rely on their good work and sometimes
I work might be a little bit sloppy so
if your program really depends on a
certain type of data coming back or
something don't just rely on the status
code to tell you that that happened
you might also actually look at the data
and make sure it's that tight before you
let your program go on after the status
code which is basically the only form of
information the initial line of the
response you might want to access the
headers which can be metadata from your
response you can do that with the
headers helper function it basically
returns a named list of all the headers
the key values are the names and the
values are the elements in this list and
then you can access a particular one
using the dollar sign syntax that you
would with the list so here I'm
accessing the server
and its value was in gif X and then the
contents if you are collecting data this
is where the data will be I'll be in the
content which is also the body of your
message you can access the content using
the list syntax with our Sun content and
what you'll get is this this is you know
the raw bytes that were sent back
through your HTTP message as an hour
user that's probably not what you want
to work with that thing of the day so
there's a helper function that can help
you extract and then parse those raw
bytes back in today that you you can
access easily and that helper function
is content so I'm using content on our
object and then you can specify the
content what format you want that that
content back in if you want those raw
bytes you can use raw and you get the
same raw bytes as using the dollar sign
but if you prefer the content as text
you can use text and then a hitter will
parse that raw data into text for you
and this is what we get here and then
you could also just ask hitter to parse
it and personal look at the header that
describes the content that's in the body
it will recognize that content if it's
one of these familiar contents over here
which are some of the most popular and
then it will convert the raw bytes into
that content into an our list for you to
use so so
content of our parsed this content was
JSON and we get it back as an englis and
then you can use to your our mechanics
for working with lists to access in
different parts of the content in this
content here by the way just built a web
page so this is basically a JSON format
for web page if truncated the contents
here because there's quite a bit so that
is all the basics of using hitter it
might have seemed really simple but
really all you are doing is making
requests to a server and then collecting
responses from the server the magic
happens with what you do with those
requests and those responses here I
focus on getting information back from
the server because normally I think the
use case for us will be there's data on
the server to that particular URL we
just want to get it so we can access it
manipulate it however you could use this
technology to manage a web page from our
and you could post new pages with posts
you could update pages with PUD and you
could delete pages delete and then there
are other HTTP verbs that have their
equivalents HTT our function in HR
package you can look at the help page
for that package to find them all
they're little less useful less general
so I didn't cover them but let's move
out of the slides and into our studio
and take a look at how we might use this
to do a simple data collection task I'm
going to use a website called own db-api
if you've ever been to IMDB the internet
movie database it contains information
about movies when they canal who the
actors where the characters were what
the plot was well oh md b contains that
same sort of information but it's an
open movie database it is an api on the
web with data about movies they exist
for people to connect to to collect that
data and then use it this is a very nice
api they want to be a thoughtful as
possible so the front page actually
talks about like how you can use this
API and so it's unique features to get
stuff and then down here we could just
type in frozen it if we wanted for
example to collective measure movie
frozen search for it finds movie frozen
it says look if you want to request the
data i have about the movie frozen it's
all stored at this URL here so i'm going
to copy that
I'm gonna go to our studio I have a
script here that Ari has this because I
copied it earlier but that's just the
URL I got from Konya
oh and db-api I'm loading the editor
package I'm saving this URL and I'm
going get coming in make this that's
very obvious I'm going to use a git
command to collect the resources I've
been URL guess it's important to run the
entire script alright now what I saved
in frozen is you know this Reese this
response I got back from the skit
request
I just got it stashed to on me that
that's good that means this worked and I
got some JSON data it's about one
kilobyte of data if I wanted to look on
some I can write an opinion here this is
the sort of stuff that you find on IMDB
that's DB you creates let's save this
the details and if I was particularly
interested in it so that I could then
just look at hook it up in this
heartless it's 2013 I have the list I
can use an R as I like as long as I know
what URL so look for at least the
structure of the URLs I can implement
all this into a program maybe I have a
for loop or a map function you drape
over a set of URLs collect all their
data extract the you component and then
I could have a set of years for
different movies and so on so this is
how you use HTT
to access data that's been provided over
a web api all right so that's about half
an hour and that was all the material
i've prepared about HT t TR so now let's
let's take some questions we have some
time for that open the questions and pop
it out it's available can I give another
example to you I could if I knew no the
URL it's it really is this simple I mean
basically I'm just teaching you the
syntax for one function and how to
interpret the results and you could
apply it to the other functions
something that might be a little
elucidating is if we actually do look at
the
for package [ __ ] so this opens up a
whole a list of all the help pages in
this package and one neat thing about
seeing this list is you can get a feel
for what functions are in the package
because every function has a help page
leads to the wealth document package and
here we could see what you know what's
there but the capital function names are
the different verbs you can use the
patch post put retry I guess this is
just that it's in our help page for yes
by check some and getting ethic and ease
with a Kray argument I by Sekulow I say
hello I don't know if this was a
response to a conversation you had but
yes there are other arguments all of
these functions so if you want to learn
a more complete way of using everything
depending on what your needs are and the
easiest way would be to look up the h TT
r package on crayon and this view that
cran provides will show you for any
package all the vignettes that they have
so if you want to get started with with
HT t are here's the quick start vignette
that goes into it a little more deeply
and then here's some best practices for
writing api's yourself these were both
written by Hadley Wickham the package
saw third and they can take much more
information I plan to go into today
working on data on hundreds of movies
that wants by Stephen Spitz Steven this
would be in case where you have to
assemble the gate function components
into a for loop or what I would suggest
is a map function from the per package
which is a little more efficient but you
have to write a program or a script that
will tell are to send a request for
every movie and then tell our what to do
with response that gets back for every
movie that shouldn't take too much time
and it's completely possible to do and
then
question is similar how to instruct our
to get the full list of movies again you
would have to know what the exhaustive
list was if you had that list of movies
and they'd be very easy to iterate over
those movies or if you had some sense of
how om DB structures its URLs so you
could programmatically change the
components until you're satisfied you've
gone through them all then you could do
that too om DB I haven't worked with it
too much because I'm not I haven't done
anything with movie database data that
I'd want to spend time on but they might
actually giving the care that they've
taken to create some your database make
it easy to access the entire list could
we use this for a web site like Yelp
what depends let's go determine whether
or not you could use this technology for
a website and just saw the flag sorry I
think sighs what determines when I use
this technology for website will depend
on whether the website contains an API
for accessing the data not every website
does but many websites do I don't know
if Yelp has an API but if I want to find
out I would start by googling it and it
looks like it does so yes you could use
this and then if I was going to do that
agree the documentation for the API for
Yelp web api that you find will be based
on HTTP the record that gets the post
those verbs but they might have deeper
features that you could take advantage
of that their documentation will tell
you how they do and normally those
features you take advantage of by adding
things to the URL that you passed your
request how do you learn what parameters
our Web API will offset by serving well
this is a good case for DLP when someone
creates an API for someone else to use
they add any features to it they need to
document their self the creator of the
API so the Yelp developers here they
have complete control of what they want
to put into the API and what they want
to make available and there's no real
standard other than using HTTP that they
don't feel obliged to stick to so
there's no universal rule you have to
learn about the API you're trying to
access
it's like person what package could be
used to take the get input and fur it
into a data frame or iPod to get input
itself that's just function arguments
whatnot but I suspect Jordan that you're
talking about the response that you get
back from get and the package that I
would use to do that is most likely JSON
light it depends on if the content of
that body actually comes back as JSON
but that would be the most common way
for the data to come back and then with
the JSON light package you could use
from JSON to turn that right into a list
which you give then make a data frame
with that stuff data frame if the
content comes back is something
different it's either going to be text
which you know just have to use text
manipulation tools I there probably is a
package I haven't worked with that you
suspect of it but if it's not JSON or
text it will be XML and then you can use
the XML package or even though the XML
to package which serves the same role as
JSON like does for JSON it makes it easy
to work with XML data and are by
changing the XML data format into are
taking formats like lists and data
frames do you ever need a special
exploit access an API stevis bits yes
you almost certainly do and and then so
Heelys question after this is is similar
can use OAuth 2.0 authentication with
its hdt r package request so yes a lot
of API is do actually want to protect
their data or at least know who you are
if you're coming to use the data so they
require some sort of authentication you
can use authentication with with HDR
HTTP our package here we're going to be
on my abilities as a statistician to do
things but if you want to say HTTP
authentification I'm in the helping to
forget it has a link right here to
authenticate which is the helper
function in HCR that will help you do
that then there's some examples down
here about how you could go about that
so if you wanted to send a get request
to for example HTTP bin which we were
using earlier you can sign rights that
URL but if you
then to keep the user and a password you
dad authenticate to the requests and it
would add your user and password to the
HTTP message that sense the same way
like adding add headers adds headers to
your message I don't have any examples
to show you about that if my job as a
firewall how do I ask ID to let me
through so backing it dear if you have
far that's obviously difficulty this is
a place where I'm go out the point I
myself would have to ask IT and I would
be very dependent on what they tell me
back so I'm unmuted I could tell you is
that you should ask I team they doing
what I T does on daily basis should be
familiar with how to give you permission
to go through a firewall how do you make
sure you don't overload the web server
with requests well if you are on meeting
your work with the map function or a for
loop there will be a lot of requests and
depending on what's our defensive
measures that web site adds to prevent
you know BOTS or whatnot you might have
to you know have a system sleep between
each iteration so they don't have to
laugh another core not but if you're
working with an Web API they are likely
expecting lots of requests I mean this
is a way to transfer data so if you're
working something going DB which is
purposely sending data across you might
not run into the overload that you
expect if you're working with a basic
website which just thinks users aren't
visiting it and the API you're relying
on is the web browser API to build that
website well if you hit that frequently
you yeah you might trigger some requests
on some some security it says like you
know too many requests in a certain time
frame I think you know this is some sort
of cyberattack and I think the best way
to deal with that would be systole okay
John has a very insightful question how
can you contrast Hitler with our vest so
our vest is a package that's designed to
help you scrape you two off the web in
our vests will be the topic of the
November 30th workshop
our inventors really I have more
experience I like and I said a few times
or it's come out if she does I don't
work with where the API is that often
but I do scrape data off the web for me
I'm most interested in just like
idiosyncratic data that probably isn't
shared over an API but it is on a
webpage so an example of this would be
if we didn't go to om DB people went to
IMDB which is the Internet Movie
Database you know there's all sorts of
data here let's just pick a movie the
lego Pat made me I hope I didn't choose
my truck stop I almost Christmas down
here either
table of actors and actresses and what
roles they play there's comments
metadata attribute all these things are
data that's in this webpage if we wanted
to look at the source of a webpage you
know we will see a lot of HTML but in in
that HTML there's the data that we were
looking at it hasn't been put in a place
that's easy for us to access so if we
wanted it if we basically have to take
down this HTML and do you know character
processing and string processing on it
to get the date we want back from it
that's what I'm calling web scraping and
that's what the Arvest package is
designed to do it's a down and dirty way
to just go in there and take what you
want and probably cause illegal if you
try to sell it or something on but it
gives you full freedom to get anything
you see on the Internet and that's what
we'll talk about next time HTTP our is a
much more mannerly package it's for data
that the people who put on the internet
expected others to come get and they've
organized it in a nice neat way and
they've arranged so when you send them
to get requests you can get back a
response with the data in it so if you
if you're contemplating web scraping and
I'll say some of our three is two the
first thing you should always do is
check to see if the data's available
through some sort of API because it
would save you a lot of time if you can
use HTT you will save a lot of time our
vest is a messy data they really have to
clean up so the difference between HTT
our and our vests is the difference
between api is and web scraping this is
a convenient place to stop I apologize
if I haven't answered some of your
questions my take-home message to is
that this technology is fairly simple at
the level we're using it and you can
just build on it from there if you want
to go further start with the vignettes
for HTTP
[Music]